on Prime crime
a young life is cut short she shot twice
closed the Gap and shot four more times
but the question of why Ryan always put
pressure on me to orgasm is not so
simple to answer I'm right here
I gave him his nose dog he wanted
[Music]
hi there everybody I'm Jesse Weber and
welcome to Prime crime this is where we
break down the most high profile and
memorable True Crime cases a young
couple's relationship comes to a lethal
end and it's the police interrogation
tape that leaves everyone asking why did
this happen
October 12 2012 Highland Heights
Kentucky the man you're seeing is Ryan
Poston a 29 year old lawyer who had
plans to go out that night but as you're
about to see that never happened
ma'am I killed my boyfriend in
self-defense that is 21 year old grad
student Shayna Hubers postings on-again
off-again girlfriend
completely bad
15 minutes ago
ma'am I don't know what they'll do I
mean
later on that night Hubers is brought
into a room at Police Headquarters
I don't know what's going on can I talk
to you even without an attorney present
Huber has decided to just open up to the
various officers that came into the room
I think there are two different ways to
look at that number one you could say
that that's something that an innocent
person would do because they want to
explain the situation and have the
police better understand why they're
sitting that room before them or it can
be looked at that she thinks that she's
smarter than all the investigators if I
shot him in self-defense because he's
done stuff before where I've hit my head
on the headboard and could have died
Huber's lays out the details of the
shooting he's physically violent
into the dining room all the way into
the living room back into the dining
room I knew he was gonna hit me again or
throw me or something again and there
was a gut I came right there and I knew
what the next thing might have been and
I picked up the guns in the middle of
him
doing something with his arm or saying
something crazy and shot him when there
are there's a couple where one person
largely outweighs the other that if
there is some sort of sort of abuse the
weapons must or can be used to overcome
that fear of death and eminent harm
that him hitting me versus me hitting
him it's not really
you can even buy his clothes guns on me
as jokes before and I said I think that
was in mind it was commonplace for Ryan
to have guns ammunition strewn about his
house in all different areas he was a
gun advocate and what would you what
would you do if I saw you
I was afraid however there are some
issues with Huber's account you can see
from the living room that's not how it
happened
if you walk in there yeah think's wrong
it doesn't look right yeah you know it's
a disarray the crime scene shows us
there are no disturbances in the living
room that would prove that any kind of
knockout drag out fight even occurred
the coffee table the kitchen table were
covered with items nothing was knocked
over and the TV that she claimed she was
shoved into had layers of dust on it and
nothing was Disturbed when I
shot in the face and he could put his
arm across the table and have it in my
face it wasn't completely standing up he
was like this
the shell casings that were found in the
home two were in one area four in
another but all in close approximation
what it showed is that she shot twice
closed the Gap and shot four more times
and he was laying with his face on the
table like twitching I knew he was gonna
die
a very slow and painful death so
I saw him
enough time
to kill him so that he wouldn't suffer
thought it was completely dead and he
was laying there still
Twitter and making noises
and I shot him in the head shooting
somebody initially in the head is an
example of somebody who wants somebody
dead otherwise you know self-defense
would be shooting as fast as you can and
then leaving the scene which she had
ample opportunity to do I killed him in
a mechanism of self-defense or shot at a
mechanism of self-defense
and then knew he was going to die so
put him out of the
misery shout him multiple times and put
him out of his misery as a curious
statement it's a hard enough thing to do
to just kill someone it's a hard thing
to do to pull the trigger and shoot
someone potentially being something that
is more nefarious and more sort of evil
than perhaps it actually was I do I
think she was trying to put him out of
this misery I think she thinks she was
trying to put him out of his misery
I've picked up the phone
and called my mother and said Mama what
did I do
said
you call the cops
call a call the fact that she did call
her mother and call 9-1-1 10 to 15
minutes after the incident she wanted to
ensure that Ryan was dead
I think I deserve you
as you'll see though this case isn't
open and shut I've learned that a
person's inability to have any kind of
remorse or empathy or dealing with some
kind of mental health issue
foreign
[Music]
like I didn't just like thought and kill
a dude in 2012 out in Kentucky 21 year
old Shayna Hubers is telling police the
circumstances surrounding the shooting
death of her boyfriend 29 year old Ryan
Poston it wasn't killing it because I
was spiteful it wasn't killing him
because I'm done with the relationship
it was
you're evil
and you've been throwing me around the
room like a rag doll she claimed Poston
got physical with her that night and she
killed him to save her life one below
and he could kill me the words came the
worst I'm rather he's dead than on her
because I could have been really badly
hurt but as she goes on certain aspects
of the story are peculiar like how many
times she shot him I shot it once
and didn't shoot again for a while but I
was watching him die
but it was so painful
to watch him die he walked around the
table and shot him where I knew he would
die immediately I shot him probably six
times and despite Huber's describing a
chaotic fight you can't
throw somebody
I probably have rug Burns I'll probably
do have some bruises there was no
evidence of injuries and the crime scene
wasn't in disarray but Huber's displays
other odd behavior when alone in the
interview room such as dancing
singing
and seemingly boasting
yes I did
not believe I did that lack of remorse
the lack of empathy again she's showing
she's in a place of complete
self-preservation you think they're
going to take me
well here's a good question
if I had to go to jail can you shower
there I have to shower in front of
people oh
oh my God
is it indicative of of No Remorse it's
certainly possible but I think that
there's an alternative I don't think
she's that sophisticated in her thinking
somewhat childlike that these were kinds
of behaviors that she was doing at cell
student keep her distracted from what's
going on internally
will they marry me if they know that I
killed my boyfriend
foreign
for killing Ryan is yet another example
of her inability to place herself in
Ryan's shoes and even the members of his
family who she had grown to know I can't
even imagine like what people are gonna
say about me
[Music]
yet there may be something a lot deeper
Happening Here
when I'm looking at Shayna right now I
am seeing someone who is suffering from
borderline personality disorder symptoms
issues with her own identity issues with
relationships can't manage her emotions
and that leads to one of the most
shocking comments Huber's made I
couldn't then watch him twitch and if he
was going to die or have it completely
deformed face
he's very vague and wants to get a nose
job and I shall I'm right here
I gave him his nose job he wanted the
fact that she was making jokes about
maiming and killing an individual who
she claims that she loved just showed
how disconnected she really was perhaps
pathologically from the acts that she
did when we returned we'll get into more
of the backstory between Ryan and Shayna
that may provide a further explanation
of what happened behind closed doors
this whole deal just cut to the chase to
the to go to meet Ryan
and did you ever hear from Ryan again
yeah
I'm not your typical murderer he said
you're just to help it away from
Kentucky and I am if I if the hillbilly
came out of me
in October 2012 21 year old Kentucky
Woman Sheena Hubers is recounting to law
enforcement how she shot and killed her
29 year old boyfriend Ryan Poston in
what she claims was self-defense I feel
really bad about it because I really
loved him but he was so abusive to me as
the interview progresses Shayna begins
to show a deeper lack of remorse that
can be sitting here like oh I hope
Ryan's family doesn't hate me
um it is hurt
are you deserved it is there a
possibility that she viewed her life as
being endangered certainly possible but
I think for her it was more that she
wasn't getting what she needed out of
the relationship and that made her angry
which is one of the common issues and
common complaints of someone with
borderline personality disorder is that
they cannot seem to manage their own
emotions if you could put his arm across
the table and have it in my face and was
screaming at me at the top of his lungs
the investigation would show that Ryan
and Shayna had a toxic relationship it
appears that this was a classic
tumultuous relationship but it did seem
from the evidence more one-sided meaning
he was trying to get out of the
relationship and trying to end the
relationship where she was continually
invested in the relationship showing up
unannounced the sheer volume of
communication between the two was
troubling there was approximately 50 000
text messages approximately 20 000
social media Communications and
thousands of photographs and it was
largely initiated by her in fact the
night that Shayna killed Ryan the Young
attorney had a date with who Miss Ohio
we became connected on Facebook how long
would you say you all were messaging via
Facebook say just a few days it's how
did he strike you
funny funny and smart but where did you
all agree to meet
um we agreed to meet at like a gas
station that was like nearby at first
and then he I didn't hear from him and
so I just went to the place to kind of
like see if maybe it was bad
communication and I kind of like looked
around a little bit but he wasn't there
did you wait yeah did Ryan ever show
yeah and did you ever hear from Ryan
again I don't think Ryan was ever in the
relationship the way Shayna would have
wanted him to be throughout their entire
time together Ryan probably always had
one foot out the door I'm not surprised
that he had a date that night and I
think that it might have been something
that kind of prompted uh Shannon to
engage in the act that she probably
wouldn't have done otherwise I was like
begging him to stay in the relationship
and be with me but you get to the point
where
add an option it does seem to believe
that she's justified in murdering him
because she was angry and she just could
not take being dumped and moving on and
that was her complete Revenge was that
if I can't have him nobody will happen
right now okay with everything that we
have
um
we're gonna I'm gonna try I'm gonna have
to charge you with murder
Sheena Hubers was arrested and charged
with the murder of Ryan Poston but
here's where the story takes a wild
detour in 2015 Hubers went to trial she
was convicted by a jury of her peers and
sentenced to 40 years in prison yet that
verdict was overturned her conviction
was overturned because juror 499 did not
disclose that they had a felony
conviction and in Kentucky a felony
conviction precludes juror service now
Huber's had a second chance at freedom
and her new defense team went forward
with a different strategy he lost the
initial trial because of number one her
only form of defense was self-defense
she hadn't introduced the extreme
emotional disturbance angle until the
second trial
extreme emotional disturbance is shown
by the defense when the individual
becomes so enraged or upset that their
judgment and their ability to act is
clouded due to this extreme emotional
disturbance up next will this jury
convict Hubers of murder when he was
first shot he let out a really loud
noise that sounded like an animal
if someone else was in the room and they
watched it go down
they would have been like
good for her
in 2018 Kentucky Woman Shayna Hubers
heads to trial for a second time for the
murder of her boyfriend Ryan Poston who
she shot to death in his apartment after
what she says was a violent encounter
while a jury had previously convicted
Huber's that verdict was thrown out due
to juror misconduct now in her retrial
instead of relying solely on
self-defense her team focused more on an
alternative defense that Shayna acted
due to an extreme emotional disturbance
I I was hysterically crying and
I recall
Ryan standing over me
and grabbing the gun that was sitting on
the table and pointing it at me and
saying
I could just kill you right now in order
to understand the circumstances of that
night Huber's first explained both the
trauma in her life I was sexually
assaulted in the restroom by a stranger
and what she claimed was mistreatment
and abuse at the hands of Poston I fear
him I felt like
I needed to do what he was telling me to
do one of the good arguments from
extreme emotional disturbance was this
perceived abuse that she had discussed
that she was put down insulted that he
had continually broken up with her and
that she felt continually rejected Ryan
always put pressure on me to orgasm he
put pressure on me to
at rest
breast implants he felt like my lack of
or my inability to orgasm was due to
psychological Trauma from my past the
sex became rough Ryan
did something I didn't want him to do
and this all came to a head on the night
of the shooting in
and he screamed at me you're a fucked up
person
and you're a person
because you're you were touched when you
were a little girl and that's why that's
why you can't orgasm and that's why I
can't love you and that's why Noah will
ever be able to love you standing up
from the chair and he was reaching
across the table
and I don't know if he was reaching for
the gun or reaching for me and I got up
off the floor and I grabbed the gun
and I shot him kind of suggesting
extreme emotional disturbance I could
see where they're coming from given the
diagnosis is a borderline personality
disorder what they're saying is that in
the heat of this moment right something
was going on that led me to thinking
things that I wouldn't have thought
otherwise I couldn't think of the right
thing to do at that moment the
prosecution though said what Shayna did
was a cold deliberate and unjustified
killing on that night
Shayna Huber murdered Ryan Poston
not out of self-defense
not because she wasn't in control
but because she was not going to allow
him to reject her
and move on to be with someone else the
fact that Sheena fired at his face
showed that she wanted him dead
continued shooting as what we call
intentional Overkill and plus we all we
already know that she had a plan of
killing him and pretending like it was
an accident when she texted a friend
earlier that week
to whom Miss Huber sent this message
to myself to me when I go to the
shooting range with Ryan tonight I want
to turn around shoot and kill him and
play like it's an accident interestingly
the statements that the defendant used
on the 9-1-1 team and when she was
speaking with officers were really the
worst things against her
place
that he's doing this extreme reaction to
this abandonment could really send
someone over Edge that said there's a
real disconnect between that emotional
reaction and murder
as the jury reached a verdict yes sir is
what you have the jury's verdict
in your hand yes we the jury find the
defendant Shayna Huber's guilty of
murder under instruction number five
despite a different defense strategy
going to trial for a second time was a
risk that ultimately didn't pay off
because not only was Huber's convicted
again unlike the jury in her first trial
that recommended 40 years in prison this
panel had other ideas we the jury fixed
the defendant Shawna Hoover's punishment
for the offense of murder at life
imprisonment
this doesn't necessarily mean that the
27 year old will spend the rest of her
life Behind Bars Huber's is eligible for
parole in 2032. when you're looking at
the parole board they take some factors
into the case had the person got
educated while they were in jail are
they reformed 20 years from now we don't
know how how Shayna is going to evolve
in the prison system personally I don't
think she deserves she took Ryan's life
when somebody takes somebody's life
intentionally they should serve a life
in prison without any opportunity to be
released
Ryan was in law school at the time and
he came to me and he hands me this paper
it was a form to change his name
he changed his name because he said Dad
this is who I am Brian Carter Poston
and I wanted you to know that and I said
great you don't have to do this for me
though this is this for you
and so that's what he did that's just
how we raised him
[Music]
the death of Ryan Poston is senseless it
is tragic and it's just overall
incredibly sad whether Shayna Hubers is
ever paroled it won't change what she
did or what she said she'll always have
to live with that and for someone who
seemingly was so concerned with how the
world would see her for many the only
viewer is one thing a murderer
that's all we have for you here on Prime
crime as always thanks for joining us
and until next time stay safe
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]